hey yeah
[Music]
hey what are those legs doing oh my
goodness oh
wa oh I'm not allowed to film in the
store uh we are picking some felt and
fabrics for be's hat that we're
doing uh he's going to get a wizard
hat
no
[Music]
no you see this happy boy we're going
bouldering
[Music]
okay
I almost stepped on him pretty sure it's
a
female
ah
okay there you
go no who's
here is it oh my God he's ready to
sleep are you ready to go to
bed hey go
yes so cozy okay good night
be we got a present from our neighbors
which
is two books oh that's so cute this is a
famous story in Japan the Peach Boy Muki
m neigh our neighbors are so nice we
also got clothes from another
neighbor cuz they saw
be let me tell you something that you
maybe not want to hear about but I think
it's important did you know your data
your personal data is being traded
collected sold like it's Pokemon cards
stolen like candy from a baby traded
like the finest Charizard that was the
best analogy I could think of at the end
of the day it's your private information
that's getting tossed around by
different companies but why should you
care well these usually contain a
frightening amount of personal details
you'll be amazed to find out what they
know about you and this can all be used
against you by different entities
whether it's insurance companies Banks
even the government if you're getting a
bunch of spam calls that's usually an
indicator that your personal data is out
there and someone is abusing it but most
of the time you don't even know about it
to me it's crazy how this is even legal
but at the very least the goodness is
that it's you have the right to get
swiped off from these data Brokers the
problem however is that this would
literally take up years it could take
years to do this on your own and I don't
think you have that sort of time I don't
at least I don't even have 10 minutes
that's why I've been using incog which
is a service that does all this for you
you don't have to lift the finger and
they've been pretty fast as well you
just sign up sit back and relax and let
incog do the hard work for you hold
up oh that's good I know incog is doing
something
because I've been getting updates
throughout apparently I'm listed on 58
of them how it's good to know most of
them 37 has been already completed that
feels really good because I don't like
my personal information being out there
and I don't think you should either so
check it out link is in the description
go to in
cog.org
it take advantage of this deal you're
welcome get your personal data swiped
off the market thank you incog for spons
in this
[Music]
video oh he touched
it yeah yeah so
strong hey G
M oh he oh he's a little
shy hey oh
mama oh my
God oh my
God check this guy out no I saw where
you landed you can't
[Music]
escape waa what a jump all right he
doesn't like
me
[Music]
yay he loves it
bye-bye a mama pulled me damn it even be
caught one well done be what do we find
here
[Music]
yes
who's
stronger hey gar be
[Music]
careful since I got into bouldering I
got these holds to sort of practice
finger strength so I started with this
one then you go to 25 mm then you go to
20 then you go to 15 which is really
difficult but then there's this one at
the back which I thought was just like a
meme the 10 mm one it's like
nothing uh but I think I can do it I
wanted to try
it here goes
nothing
hey what was that 4 seconds that's
pretty cool really hurts my hands though
damn that's
crazy making
[Music]
progress
oh is that comfortable I don't think it
is okay oh you made it nice Year too do
you want to try a pumpkin nyaki that
momy
made
where we visited like 10 times before
coming to
Japan and we've been here a year now but
we haven't done done a really toury
thing which is cool though we should see
the Imperial Palace every time we come
it's been closed am I filming directly
into the sun right now I think I
am but anyway we're going
now that's a poor woman walking behind
me who doesn't want to be part of the
rock not bad it's an a cool view
here we're always too lazy to take these
paths hey there we are
yeah don't drop your phone fix
okay it's free to enter I didn't know
that it's probably a cool view up there
let's go and check it out
okay don't walk off the giant Stone
thing it's not worth
it
I'm being the neighbor's kid I'm sorry I
like the bike
broom did you like that love that that's
my
girl do you want some bamboo fun
facts uh they can grow more than a meter
in a day yeah okay I knew that you knew
that yeah uh something new they release
30% more oxygen than regular trees okay
and there's little people living
[Music]
inside there's not much Palace at the
Imperial Palace but it's really pretty
it was destroyed during the second world
war but rebuilt in similar
[Music]
style so much interesting stuff to
tell
did you see that he tried to go for it
oh bless
[Music]
you recently I discovered that I had a
bunch of people that are members and I
have not done anything for
members since a year ago and a wave of
guilt just hit me and cuz people are
paying and I thought it could be fun to
play Let's Plays like the good old days
10 minute
episodes CU that's really all I have
time to do
anyway uh so I've been replaying it for
members I'll probably upload these later
at some point let maybe like 6 months
from now or something so everyone can
watch it but if you want to they're
there every single day new part 10
minutes check it out we will soon make a
brief up at
passengers changing into the
[Music]
me
it's a mirror
Mama it's you it's literally
[Music]
you
that we're going to check out Yokohama
English Gardens find some pumpkins I
think I found one
already
beautiful
at he's faking being
[Music]
dead
these smells so nice they're everywhere
blooming in Tokyo right
now little pumpkin that's so
[Music]
pretty is looking at
himself who that handsome boy
[Music]
happy birthday dear
Maria happy birthday
to
you what did I do to
him that bear got
desecrated that's
made we are set up we're tarped
up today's Mar's birthday and it's also
the yearly
fireworks so we're really lucky with the
timing I'm setting up early we saw it
four years ago and then they canceled a
couple years because of coid I think so
we're really excited that it's back it's
a really cool
fireworks uh
spectacle they do like Smiley faces and
like anime figures with fireworks it's
super cool um but we also saw it like 4
years ago before we moved here and it
was at the time that we had decided that
we were going to move
so it feels like it feels special to see
it see these yearly fireworks we saw it
before we wanted to move and now we're
seeing it as we moved here so I think
that's really cool very much looking
forward to it and the weather's good so
yeah we're lucky oh my God
happy birthday to
[Music]
you I remember there were a lot of
wa how did they do it I need a smiley
face on
camera
wow
[Music]
there
that tastes so good like
strawberry yum yum
happy birthday to who
birthday I wish for babies to
sleep all across the world M makes this
every year is Tiger ccka it's
like chocolate sugar
cake
M it's so nice oh I love it wonderful
10 out of 10 I'm awake now so that
helps thank it's from edar such
beautiful handwriting it's a toothbrush
cuz I brush your teeth I can brush your
teeth with this eggy thank
you and this is from Mama dear daddy a
joyous day I've always wanted to play
this that's perfect it's from
Yan let's see your handwriting okay not
bad the gift from me to me and you
you're welcome
Bernie thank you Bernie
[Music]
oo we're going to
make what does yours say Minnie I
thought it said
mint
yay
yay it is a beautiful October day hey
it's my birthday I forgot about that so
I get to Surf today it's been two months
not a lot of Surfing since becoming a
dad I never been to this beach before so
I want to check out before I commit
that's a lot of people looks fun might
do that oh even there's good waves good
break over there maybe I'll do
that
the waves are kind of far and few in
between but the ones I rode felt really
really nice I'm so
lucky so happy I got to do this I'm uh
just taking a quick break I'm going to
go maybe 20 more minutes and then head
back for lunch and then Mar is joining
me and be and we're going to do it
together well they're going to watch me
it's so amazing that you can surf in
late
October and it's not cold at all it's
really nice actually
I love
[Music]
it he lik
that what do you
[Music]
do oh that's so cute I didn't know I got
to try
[Music]
[Laughter]
that
the rarest of the
mall a sleepy
[Music]
M wo it's a
banana what an
outfit
[Music]
yes
that muskat flavor is so
[Music]
good
I'm here I know all the Kung Fu H
H we're just chilling for B you know
broke
talk it is such a nice autumn
day I love it we're going to get some
Halloween candy for tomorrow uh do the
same we did last year where we put out
some candy M we already had some early
ones the candy is gone the cand is gone
we need more trying to find a way to go
down we need an escalator let me
show they've stopped already it's not
even Halloween yet everything is like
can uh Christmas
there all right we got plenty I
think might say's feeding the whole
neighborhood
[Music]
we got a package be you want to open it
yay birthday gift it's my birthday Bai
NCO Fun For All into the future
oo thank you holy that is
lit
I actually love it that is
ridiculous wow thank you I'm definitely
building that oh you're going to fall
off Oh no you're falling off to your
demise you're becoming like egar you're
trusting daddy too
much
[Music]
hello
happy
Halloween what this is weird this is not
a Halloween pumpkin let me feel
it mother you can't even hold
[Music]
it
every year I hate carving I mean scoping
scraping the
pumpkins but not this year okay okay so
one crying baby and panic carving later
we have maras very cute another Maria
although I carved it and then I don't
even
know uh that's fine oh I'm such a pretty
girl
happy Halloween
guys I'm wearing makeup in case I look
insane Halloween
Kiss Halloween
kiss
fine you look so beautiful
M we're putting out candy that Merc has
repair anyone I want to and there's a
hand in there that's so
pretty let's see can I carry this
without disaster
[Music]
okay walk in like Michael Jackson Traer
first
obacle oh
[Music]
gosh